STEPHEN CARPENTER: I have two
activities that I've prepared.
So interpretation, this idea
of constructing meanings
or developing meanings
about works of art,
or we can think
of interpretation
as someone is
speaking one language
and then we take that
language and we are able to--
not only do we speak and
understand this language,
then we can take those
ideas and those words
and turn them into
a different language
that someone else speaks.
We can have interpretation
function in that way as well.
So it's about taking
ideas from one context
into another or one mode of
representation in communication
into another.
But in terms of art
and art practice,
art criticism and
interpretation work together.
So this image I think is
useful for our purposes here.
Imagine that this
image was the poster
for a movie, full length,
feature length movie.
And imagine you were responsible
for writing the copy--
for writing the text for the
voiceover of the movie trailer,
but all you had was
this image to go by.
You probably heard
movie trailers,
those little
commercials for movies.
And usually my
experience, they start off
with one of two phrases or a
version of one of two phrases.
One of the phrases
is usually something
like this, "Imagine a
place--" And you can imagine--
you've heard this phrase
before from movie trailers.
"Imagine a place" and the
music is start doing [HUMMING]..
You see the scenery.
Another phrase that is often
used is "In a world where--"
You've--
I see nodding going on,
so that means, oh, I've--
you could probably
name several films
that have movie trailers
that start that way.
So take one of those phrases--
"imagine a place," or
"in a world--" and--
I don't know if you have
something to write with
or if you want to
keep it in your head.
And if you come up a sentence
or two, that would be great.
But the sentence or two that
starts with one of those two
prompts would function as
the beginning voiceover copy
for the movie from
which this still comes.
We got it?
All right.
Here's the movie trailer.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- What would you do in
a world without justice?
In 2017, humankind's
most precious resource
is used as a weapon of control.
Will you punch up against power?
[END PLAYBACK]
STEPHEN CARPENTER: I'm
going to that movie.
[LAUGHS] Wow, all right.
So part of what I'm hearing--
like I heard swimming upstream,
adversity, these water hoses,
I heard--
there was an issue of
control, resistance.
This border wall
suggests there's
something about being
in and out and not
being able to attain something.
And then the X Games--
what'd you call it?
Cheerleading?
Extreme-- ultimate cheerleading.
Extreme cheerleading.
So there's an activity,
but then there's
something else that
pushes it or ramps it up.
Add some context here.
This is a still image from
a performance by performance
artist Dread Scott.
The title of the work is
called, On the Impossibility
of Freedom in a Country Founded
on Slavery and Genocide.
And he's referencing
a range of events,
but specifically
a particular event
in the '60s where
there was a protest
against racial injustice.
Where the authorities
used water hoses,
high-powered water hoses to
push back African Americans.
This was not a single
event, these kinds of things
happen all the time in the '60s.
So this is part of Dread
Scott's performance,
this is a still from
his performance.
I find it remarkable listening
to even the comedy trailer,
that you were picking
up on elements of what
his performance--
what he intended his performance
to be about, but also what
other people have interpreted
his performance to be about.
Charles Garoian is a performance
artist an art educator
who also taught high school in
the Bay Area in San Francisco.
And he taught his students
in late '60s and the '70s--
into the '80s
actually I believe--
about performance
art and happenings,
and the ways in which our
bodies can perform symbolically
to construct works
of art that relate
to social issues
and cultural issues.
So his work is documented
in several of his books,
one of which is called
Performing Pedagogy where
he interprets several works
of art and performance art
and then provides
a set of activities
that teachers and their
students can perform
to learn some of
the basic structures
or some elements
of performance art
using one's body as
an artistic medium,
but also a way in which to
comment on social issues.
But it's the idea of using our
bodies as symbolic vehicles
that become powerful.
And also the ways that
our bodies can move
and the ways in which
our bodies interact
with other objects
or other ideas,
the way in which we might
maybe think of taking our body,
doing something to it,
doing something else to it.
So there's an activity that
I often do with my students--
undergrad, graduate
students, students
who are learning to
be teachers that I
borrowed from Charles Garoian.
Here's a still image of
one student doing this.
And what I'd like you to do
is to identify a statement.
Could be an excerpt, it
could be song lyrics,
it could be a poem, but it needs
to be a set of words that--
ideally it's a text or a
sentence or several phrases--
that you could or
someone else could say
within a 30-second time period.
So borrowing from Charles
Garoian's approach,
one of the activities is
to take an image and--
a body, and the body engages
in a repetitive motion,
a repetitive activity.
And the ideas that that body
in motion in relationship
to or in juxtaposition with
or in critique or conversation
with that image will inherently
start to construct or suggest
different interpretations,
just like what
you did when you saw
the image and you
added some text to that.
But there's a third
element, and that's the text
that you've come up with.
So what is going to happen--
so here's another student
doing something similar.
So what's going to happen is,
I'm going to hit this button,
and then I'm going
to go over here
and I'm going to
start performing.
I'm going to do a repetitive
motion for 30 seconds.
When I get over there, you're
going to speak your text.
AUDIENCE: Oh, my text?
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I thought
I was reading your text.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: No, no.
Oh, you would rather
not share your text?
AUDIENCE: I mean, I don't mind,
it's just not 30 seconds long.
I can say it over
and over again.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
That would be fine.
All right, we'll do that.
Then I have two
other images so we'll
be able to get to
two other people.
But you'll see how this works.
You ready?
Go.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Sometimes you gotta post
bad pictures of yourself
online so that
people are impressed
when they see you in person.
Sometimes you gotta post
bad pictures of yourself
online so that
people are impressed
when they see you in person.
Sometimes you gotta post bad
pictures of yourself online
so now people are impressed
when they see you in person.
Sometimes you gotta post
bad pictures of yourself
online so that
people are impressed
when they see you in person.
LARRY SUSSKIND: Time.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: All
right, thank you, Larry.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
STEPHEN CARPENTER: See, I had
to trust him because, you know,
three minutes could
have been 30 seconds.
You see what happened?
We have a repetitive
motion, which
might suggest certain ideas
and concepts, meanings.
We had this text.
Be where-- say it again?
AUDIENCE: Oh, sometimes
you have to post
bad pictures of yourself online
so that people are impressed
when they see you in person.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: So
not only do we have text,
we gotta put in relationship
to this movement.
But this image,
what does this image
have to do with this movement?
I mean, it's interesting, you
can put two ideas together
or put these two things together
or these two things together,
but all three of them?
Anybody want to attempt to
weave these three together?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Since the
theme of repetition,
I didn't catch it at first,
but the fact that you
kept repeating it
and then your hop
kind of synced in
with that, and then
looking at this
image, just the fact
that there's all these windows
and all the pieces of the image
deconstructed-- sort
of fell into this cycle
of posting pictures online and
seeing people multiple times
and it did sort of in
time come together for me.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: OK, nice.
So why would I do
something like that?
Well, at the end of the
semester, the students in one
of my graduate classes
I teach at Penn State
and also at Vermont
College of Fine Arts,
after going through that process
of the randomness of making
those connections,
they then have
to go through the process of
intentionally combining image,
text, and body movement
for a public performance
that lasts at
least five minutes.
So these are-- the top row
are stills from one video,
the bottom row are
stills from another one,
and the one at the top,
the student was interested
in the idea that someone told
her at one point something
like, there have
never been any wars--
international wars on US soil.
And she thought, this
doesn't make any sense,
and a history teacher
told her that.
So the idea was that this
performance speaks back
to that, and this was
performed in Philadelphia.
And so you can see in these
three different images,
she's using her body
in different ways.
She's holding a photo of--
a satellite photo
of a plane bombing.
She created almost a little
memorial and burial for this
and has watered it generously
and then puts her own body down
in this bench.
That it's essentially a
whispering bench where she
she's sitting at one end and
can whisper into the corner,
and the person sitting
at the other end
can hear what she's saying.
And the one at the
bottom is a student
who performed outside
of Karachi-- that's
at Carnegie Hall, in
front of Carnegie Hall.
And symbolically speaking
to a death in her family,
but also her own musical
aspirations and the way
in which they relate
to her own life,
but also she was equating
it to gun violence.
And so she was
cleaning the clarinet
and puts it in this
case in various ways
that make you suggest--
they suggest, is this a
musical instrument or is it
an implement for an
instrument of killing?
So these are some outgrowths
from that quick assignment
that we did.
So in summary, you
could engage learners
like we've done today
in any of these ways,
or you could do boring stuff.
It's really up to you.